hello na moto moto okay again going for
2500 will diminish mah 5 sometimes you
still get people who play into that it
seems like he doesn't mind or he just
plays quickly no matter what
it's also possible
you
it's not not clear all this pollution I
have to have had this on the board
multiple times and blitz and I mean I'm
scoring well because such such a
difficult position for for white but it
is some knots not clear here it's not
clear at all
let's see now I know I can try to win
some material Eric de 595 there should
be seven but I don't really
expect that to happen
okay
you
I think I can go green d7 first before I
do anything else
then see how to deal with that
hmm
yeah let's do that
this line is one of them a very very few
where you can actually Castle queenside
in a in an English opening
and I had no clue about this position
they're just very very murky
only white should just like
play before it hope for the best not the
best move very likely but yeah he is
going for them okay now this is
something well mmm
now you kid you couldn't think about it
but I think my well if I take point X 90
there is a form
you
okay but take d4 he might have be five
Wow
okay
before looks like it was a good move
please madness now
five but that should be done I think
don't quite know what
I do that is okay that I didn't quite
have on the radar I thought
[Music]
you
let's take this
what is he thinking about
six intermediate moves maybe
it's not ridiculous at all
Bishop takes this Bishop takes h3
does he threaten anything immediately I
don't see it so fire just fire
Bishop takes root Jade
the file okay
a 5v5 doesn't read much
I think he should should have taken I
mean it's a bit of a gamble but I think
he should have taken
g3 I don't know g3 I do I take
or g8g 8 first problem
you
Oh
hmm okay let's go away five
just
this for the moment
I think I think my check is going to be
the size of here anyway
maybe I could have played g3 and since
really I mean instead of a five but
I don't think this is very relevant
you
okay
where's the mate
still you're made Queen b3 is not made
you
just on anyway it's a bit sadistic here
probably too
wait
having some revenge checks at least no
meat okay yeah there it was a super
chaotic position very my gut feeling was
that I was versatile so somewhere here
deformed by the six
9527 let's look here before I think
before it's just like what you have to
do and I don't trust the engineer so
much at least not at this depth yeah
like depth 30 is something else but not
20 or so before however that looks fine
looks right and just played aggressively
the engine wants to play Knight to e7
okay
my my hunch is that ETA XT 4 is bad
because of b5 which she didn't play
yeah b5 strong
so this is good okay
if night xf6 must be played I'm willing
to believe that there that looks that
looks fairly ridiculous that possibly
good for black I'm just putting stuff on
the jeeva hmm yeah 97 then and Tina
should go be 5 I would have played
Knight e5 I think it was my plan at
least I mean this
it's such a just such a
chaos
v6 is good German of course yeah b5 was
very strong that probably would have
killed me
okay he took them and now it it's
getting it's good yeah ng5 is the best
move according to the cop okay I just
felt like nothing lame now we'll just
find our way okay Bishop I think taking
is what you should do before and then we
have to go from there I don't know this
it looks good yeah I get this end I
still have some attack a capelet a4 I
know I think it should be over g3 was
winning but you can still do that
III was oh oh oh wow wow I should play
g3 absolutely oh my god I mean okay no
it's easy to spot that this is winning
it's basically the game but just without
a five but here I missed this resource
very important he can take care I would
have been a chakra and then all of a
sudden it's not made anymore okay
admittedly this is still excellent for
blanket but everyone still shock to me
and I don't have the main and now I have
to win an ending
yeah the way it was it was just just oh
I probably even got some made it is
winning quite easily okay guys thanks
for watching